my Peoria how's it going welcome back to
the last episode it's gonna be a couple
episode when the deal see you down but I
think I'll finishes in this one let's go
to chapter 4 how's it going man
let's go here all right here we go
chapter 4 special round bomb sweet bomb
alright duds and die alright this [ __ ]
is doing cuz that bombs everywhere
alright this one yeah let's play with it
why not
god damn it didn't work
alright what about this one it's Confed
inside yeah hey I knew it
that was obvious ah this one yeah that
makes sense
you just [ __ ] eat it oh gosh oh you
eat everything Mike pixel isn't that
awesome good for you what about the atom
bomb yes okay if it's yeah he's like the
best that bomb that oh is this I became
a helicopter cool I haven't tried this
one what do you get it what pixel please
focus we needed finishes wow what are
you doing how'd you get bow take a [ __ ]
that's what I would do if I saw it back
well I want to take a [ __ ] again
ah it's confetti - uh how do you get
starring all of these it's a grenade I
wouldn't hold on to that it yeah now
it's a good name
but they're like different everything
Oh [ __ ] love like pixel
all right what have ideas Oh grunts how
you doing I didn't know you were there
I'm accountable now I [ __ ] ate that
booth what is that it just okay i I feel
so good why would you do that why wear
this doesn't mask it looks like a mess
what the hell did I do what about the
dynamite make it into a ribbon
ah it's not kidnap all right take this
oh look at that one pump the [ __ ] out of
that bomb like it's my night more
confetti this one
a prank neck yeah god damn it it
exploded
what about yeah ain't no pot like a
Peter pop party that's after peopie
party i buy barrel again now i'm stuck
your [ __ ] barrel you've yeah that's
what you get barrel [ __ ] [ __ ] grabs
what are you doing in there confetti I
got a head like a stop how big it like
fixer
oh you don't hump barrels I think we got
everything on the batter let's get this
one now we're we're just going
everywhere yeah in the bud car last one
where come on dude you can do better
than that
that was actually better I'm impressed
again again okay we tried all of them
now this one oh it's a fish buy off cars
we knew that
let's really again spin it and it's a
drill
come on a lot of uses for one bomb and
now did it came grabs the [ __ ] did you
do what the hell was that this look at
that no okay this what's that
what is that [ __ ] I hope it's not what I
think it what this is doing he only does
I come on all right let's check the air
it's a Jojo cuz why not uh fins all abit
man it's gone
that is just disturbing I can't get over
that pixel what are you doing now this
is okay our works
what yeah nice bling brah okay I think
we got all of them but not that one
okay i nope then we didn't do that
that's good that you did that
good job keep humping it okay we got all
of them as through this one now we got
all of them of that I wanted to forget
to love my crystal what is he doing now
what is that what's the point
I don't keep doing what you're doing
it's totally working at okay yeah let's
put it in our but why not let's check
out the dynamite grabs get out of that I
forget all the grandpa's so awesome
what the good dynamiters underway we all
knew that it's obvious what is this what
what am i watching so okay let's try the
other glass - yeah is the beverage and I
were drunk a bombs come glad that was
possible flies what else a chicken oh my
god what will look fine next of course
oh we got gold on one that means you can
get gold I want to get Iowa what I want
to get what go I want to get I want to
get I'm gonna get I wouldn't get yeah
that's fashionable oh yeah boobs that's
what what yeah yeah yeah my fix is
dry-humping a pierced a what is this uh
I sold all of them what is this what's
up man what what is he doing are we
sending bombs wait Mac pixel is the one
who sent the bomb he doesn't give a [ __ ]
all right
what is he doing with a bomb you
shouldn't drink while doing that
oh that's why it was crack in the wall
mcpixel bomb been a day and he's humping
a ps3 and it's calling from his buddy
my picture yeah let's make what's up I
have bomb beer our bomb U+ bombas what
but but oh that's a lot of money okay
okay it is that money okay fine
it's calling again okay that money okay
guy dad money and Bobby goes back to it
okay alright pixels here and that's when
we come in oh no it's over I love this
game I want more
let's dance
alright guys that is it for me I love
this game so much it's gonna be DLC
coming up totally gotta say I already
cut down anyway due to my cap you
enjoyed subscribe come over today and
I'll see you next episode on one bombing
that I really got a lot of promotion
oh man never fortune oh I'm so fat hey
please hello